heavy-handed opening shot of skulls and
cemetery to tell you Harry Potter ain't
for kids anymore
this old man noticed the light before it
was turned on hi
oh hey the Hogwarts assholes finally
stopped sending Harry back to spend
every summer with abusive relatives when
did you get just now you last night oh
wait no they didn't assholes this two
second clip of Robert Pattinson falling
out of a tree was the only audition he
needed for Twilight is the boot just
sitting out here in a field the rest of
the time when it's not being used as a
portkey did someone come out here even
earlier this morning and set it in place
while you're standing on that mic your
boots this is just any man yell boot
night it's a porky of course it is you
can now officially transport using
anything in the Harry Potter universe
that looks like one broken bone several
sprains and a handful of future
chiropractic patients Harry Potter
adults would much rather see the kids
hurt themselves than teaching them
anything useful as always oh but who put
the tent up unbelievably convenient
spell makes one wonder why there are
such things as conflicts in the magic
world I'm still trying to figure out why
stairs exist at the magical Quidditch
arena
what no magical spell or elevator now if
only somehow reaches from all the way
down here with his cane to catch some of
Harry's supposedly loose-fitting jacket
and stop him in his tracks that's racist
damn all that build-up for the Quidditch
Cup and we don't see one bit of it
what porky the boot was the port key and
then they landed in a field so are they
supposed to run back to the field or all
the way back to the random English Hill
that contains the boot also hundreds of
thousands of magical people and instead
of ganging up on a handful of Death
Eaters and overpowering them they all
scatter haven't these people seen a
bug's life main character gets separated
from the group because of an unrealistic
scuffle in a large crowd cliche so
everyone's dead or did everyone escape
and then they burned everything to the
ground you see the problem with these
cutaway two after the action is over
shots is that they confuse the fuck out
of the audience oh come on they burn
this whole place down and Harry somehow
survived the burning and the smoke
inhalation
didn't get trampled by hundreds of
thousands of people running for their
lives didn't get kidnapped by
Baltimore's minions oh the burning down
of a whole village is not the crime
they're talking about it's the scary
firework weight they're going straight
to Hogwarts after all this honestly why
even travel by water at all if you're
gonna go by magical completely submerge
boat why don't these two other schools
just have all the students take a port
key to Hogwarts it wouldn't make for
nearly as cinematic and entrance but it
definitely makes for a more logical
story Hogwarts has been chosen to host a
legendary event but try was a tournament
apparently the announcement of this very
special event just happened today with
the competing schools knowing way in
advance before any of the students at
Hogwarts did to be fair this is how we
imagine all French girls whether they
know magic or not the North isn't Victor
Krum from Bulgaria isn't Hogwarts in
England or does chrome play
professionally for Bulgarian Quidditch
team and go to school in some
Scandinavian country wait the best
seeker in the entire magical world is a
high school student this Fork was stuck
much further into this guy's hand in the
previous shop stupid tower of ice cream
scoops is stupid no strain all this we
have the head of the Department of
International magical cooperation mr.
bottom Asst crouch who isn't the least
bit busy after that terrorist attack
that happened yesterday
mad-eye moody was the only one who could
stop it from rainy roll credits Jason
now may well want to be chose wait
they're doing another triwizard
tournament in three years then why
wasn't there one during the first movie
it's not going to wha again I asked why
are the wands which bond themselves to
their owners and seem so king important
in the first movie sometimes just not
remotely necessary to fire gas one of
the other students to do it for you you
mean that could have worked if he did
the Goblet of Fire constitutes a binding
magical contract what happens if you
break the magical contract who enforces
them is there a magical contract dispute
court who represents the inanimate
goblet in these proceedings he is as of
tonight a Triwizard champion
well technically quod wizard champion
something is so obviously wrong it's
ridiculous they can't overturn this
everyone stares at the main character
POV shot cliche if we are to truly
discover the meaning of these events
perhaps we should let them unfold I
agree with Silver's
wait you mean you can do something to
keep him from play and instead you're
thinking whom what's Baltimore up to
well I better let Harry play so we can
find out now you know what bloody well
why is it so obvious to ron that harry
is a no-good liar I mean the Goblet
isn't supposed to pick four people or
two people from the same school or allow
14 year olds something is clearly wrong
Harry immediately drinks his own blood
after possibly rabid owl bites his hand
why is this the one and only time in all
eight movies when two people who need to
talk to each other while in separate
places use this fireplace phone he
doesn't the one Capulin a rising from
that company these are not just
coincidences Hogwarts isn't safe anymore
seems like I've heard this in all the
movies so far oh well if she uses magic
for the pen and paper why does she need
an actual photographer to take the
pictures oh good more movie tricks to
avoid showing the audience that while
expensive to film would actually be more
entertaining than watching Harry
listening to it also why did you put the
spectator stand so close to the
fire-breathing dragons and why did you
build it out of wood
early in this thing's firebreath
stretched like 30 feet or more in the
forest but now it goes ten feet it's a
small human sized rock and turns back
because physics this dragon chase scene
is awesome but didn't you say they'd
been given a golden egg dipper
not they've been told to kill you is the
dragon intelligent enough to know that
none of the other hundreds of people
back at the stadium are going to steal a
tag was this part of Voldemort's plan I
mean Moody is a fake Moody they staged
Harry's name being in the cup all just
to get him to win this tournament but
everything would have been if he had
slipped and died here as any non-main
character person would have the dragon
broke free from his chain and it's a
threat to the school itself and all the
students now is there any reason none of
the teachers stepped in to intervene
here what if the dragon was
fire-breathing it Harry and a bunch of
fire was headed for a section of the
stands but they've stepped in to save
the kids in the stands bull why the fuck
is this dragon climbing around the
building did it forget it can fly
they've just been listening this whole
time what they do if the dragon was
already in London ravaging muggles and
the dragon was never seen again
some say it's still falling this noise
have to be barking master your name in a
couple in five Harry and Ron's
reconciliation makes no sense
no one knew how serious the tournament
was until now not even Harry so the fact
that everyone now knows it's truly
deadly doesn't change anything about the
possibility that Harry put his own name
it if Ron was pissed before he should
still be pissed
has been a tradition of the Triwizard
Tournament since its inception now it
just sounds like you're making it up as
it goes along
also you will Baal festivities will now
take up 15 minutes of this movies time
just so we can see Ron and Hermione get
pissed off at each other
inside here we go a secret sworn
slumbers longing to burst off and take
flight from now on I'm calling my penis
secret swamp amusing scene but why does
a school stop classes to teach students
how to dance
golf gloves and diplomats - hour and 37
minute movie spends way too much time on
the giant love story wait a minute no
one's asked this girl out yet first off
that's racist second off she has so few
options that she says yes to the first
Weasley that comes along that's actually
abuse this is not a safe way to store a
boat for the winner why are they
arriving to the dance by carriage if
Hogwarts is the destination where did
the carriage rides originated supposedly
plain girl makes her grand entrance
down the stairs is a beautiful swan when
everyone is looking cliche also Hermione
isn't old enough to be hot yet won't be
too much longer though that's right you
guys I got the 14 year old I'm nailing
her in the Room of Requirement later
magic-based rock and roll act owes Billy
Idol a ton of money she has joined us
we've got care to join you Viktor jeez
Ron's character motivations are so base
he might as well just be a penis the
whole point of the tournament is
International magical cooperation what
they are cooperating they're competing
those two words are literally antonyms I
think you saw a bit more than friendship
on his mind yeah he's not the only one
you can edit that part out right this
woman's height changes in every scene
she's in baby talk uh-huh gross these
are the most Glass free glasses I've
ever seen you know the prefix bathroom
on the fifth floor it's not a bad place
for a bath if Edward Cullen is
suggesting to Harry Potter what I think
he is that beats my fanfiction
take your egg and Mull things over in
the hot water and we want to keep the
audience guessing but why wouldn't
Cedric have just said dude open the egg
underwater and listen to it phasma
phasmatis ex machina when's the last
time you held your breath underwater for
an hour a miami when's the last time
remaining had no clue what spell to cast
to get harry out of this problem the
Triwizard Tournament is a dick to
underage students who didn't even
volunteer second
my hair he gets extra points for
cheating also the only reason you made
Harry compete was because the rules were
important but now that there's life on
the line the rules am i right how does
he really have third-person views of
Dumbledore's memories give me the rigid
a bumpy Crouch jr. party jr. runs
because the accusations of a desperate
man in the cage aren't easily denied but
he had no choice the evidence was
overwhelming yeah the word of a crazy
convicted magic felon that's
overwhelming evidence for sure degrees
dad is here where's floors sad or crumbs
all right digger he's gonna die here in
a bit we need that money shot of his dad
wailing over his body
first person to touch the cup be the
winner you could have jerked off in the
first two events as long as you survive
you can win just by touching the cup
this being a maze with huge hedges this
would seem to be an awful spectator
event sportsmanship okay
why did the cup travel with him on this
journey but the boot didn't travel with
them in the initial portkey voyage
earlier in the film should i divulge how
I truly lost my parlance anything
that'll give Harry enough time to get
out of this we're all yours
when dear sweet Lily Potter gave her
life for her only son she provided the
ultimate protection a bit of magic that
saves people from the killing curse why
doesn't everybody learn this was Lily
the only one who knew how to do it
look I'm going to kill you Harry Potter
then do it already
oh hey harry and voldemort have their
wands dreams crossed you know you should
do take another for movies to get us
back to this exact same situation also
whenever my brother and I cross streams
we definitely got some on the floor
hurry take my body back buddy I'm sure
Cedric as soon as I get done battling
the Dark Lord top of my priority list
Harry is saved by some bullet ghosts
because it's a bullet having to do with
his wand and Baltimore swan connecting
or some bolt why does the port key
return them to the grandstands instead
of the spot back in the maze that they
left from parties Polyjuice potion just
happens to wear off at the right moment
for the big reveal - Harry
we will reward me I have once and for
all
silenced Harry not bad at first I
thought you weren't killing it because
of that only Voldemort gets to kill
Harry Potter nonsense but no you
could've killed him like 20 times since
he took him here you mean to tell me the
entire tournament from the beginning of
the school year until now was rigged
just to get Harry to touch a portkey
couldn't they had just made a pork knee
out of his breakfast waffles or
something Barty Crouch jr. dr. who is
that him you saw your parents that night
didn't you yeah and it was total bull
who are these people waving at and don't
give me that they're waving at the
French people on the horses nonsense
because there's no freakin way anyone
can see them this far inside the castle
over 13 minutes of prune credits I'm the
world's most dangerous predator rucu and
the exquisite Julie Madison have been
going out forever
are you going to tie the knot on the
lowest dungeon
haha speak I bought it
until at last I threw down my enemy and
smote his ruin upon the mountainside the
Yule Ball has been a tradition of the
Triwizard Tournament since its inception
do you think that miserable Oh would
have led you into the woods if I had
suggested it eccentric deathly total
Albany egg on the water if I hadn't told
him first I said think never Longbottom
the witless wonder could have provided
you with Gillian if I hadn't given the
book I let him straight to it
hey don't treat me like I'm some member
you goddamn fan club are you telling me
everybody got answers but you
Jimmy was the kind of guy who rooted for
the bad guys in the movies with Cedric
it'll be quick
you know in cinemasins land the books
may not matter but that doesn't mean
they don't exist erase from existence
many of our favorite films simply
wouldn't exist at all if it weren't for
books even if Hollywood still screwed up
most of them
you you're a new media savvy consumer
on-the-go you don't have time to sit
down and read a book got movie sins
videos to watch not to mention whatever
the hell else it is you feel your life
doing enter audible.com slash cinemasins
audible has over 150,000 audiobooks and
you're sure to find one of your
favorites narrated by someone with a
calm soothing voice it rubs the lotion
on its skin it does this whenever it's
told so get the rich storytelling and
depth of character that comes from the
books with none of the reading by
signing up today for a trial offer just
for our viewers at audible.com slash
cinemasins
today